[Applause]
Rihanna shut down the Super Bowl on
Sunday night with her headline making
halftime show complete with a pregnancy
reveal
the Super Bowl is one of the biggest
stages in the world yeah it's an
Entertainer's dream to be on a stage
like that and what lights went down on
that epic performance Riri let loose
backstage with a group of friends
[Applause]
that's a singer dancing and celebrating
backstage rocking that same Red Jumpsuit
from her performance while her Pals
waved the flag of her home country
Barbados I'm still pinching myself
really I'm grateful I'm grateful shortly
after ree stepped off the field she was
sprayed down with some celebratory
champagne before riding off on a golf
cart
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
and get this she even linked up with
Colombian Superstar and self-proclaimed
Riri Stan Carol G something that I would
love to do is performed with Rihanna so
then that's one of my biggest dreams
Rihanna if you're watching this please
call me I have a song for you yeah check
out the PowerHouse singers backstage
posing it up clearly basking in the
moment of course it was a huge night for
the Grammy winner who subtly revealed
during her performance that she's
expecting her second child with ASAP
Rocky cradling her growing baby bump
during the show
[Music]
ain't a new mom nothing would have
gotten me out the house if it wasn't a
challenge like that now a source is
opening up to ET about the massive
undertaking explaining that ree knows it
was a performance to remember and that's
what she wanted quote she loves that the
performance also acted as such an
exciting announcement for her and her
family of course Rocky and Rihanna
welcomed their first kid together a son
last May what are you looking forward to
As you move into a new chapter of your
life I'm just excited for what I don't
know yet you know everything is new to
me so you know I'm excited E.T Source
says the singer wanted to share a
message of empowerment that you can
balance it all and make your dreams come
true
but leading up to the Big Show Rihanna
played koi with ET about what fans could
expect I want to incorporate
a lot of culture I want to incorporate
different aspects of
entertainment and things that I just
enjoy and bring it to the stage you know
what I want to celebrate the music that
I've made a source at the time told E.T
she wanted to wow the audience adding
that she was so excited I've always
tried to stay and stick with things that
I enjoy doing and mostly
that I'm passionate about being creative
that's one of those things that it
doesn't matter the outlet I always enjoy
it now that the big moment's over we're
told ree's thrilled with how the show
went so let's hear it for Rihanna for
making it all truly all looks so easy